[Music]
[Applause]
get over here
I miss you guys we don't even hang out
anymore we're barely ever together as a
group well that's how it goes maybe you
just got a little stuck After High
School I did not peek in high school
everybody say yes
I have cancer
what
kind of cancer do you have
[Music]
tonsil red pepper oh yes you know what I
think I have to go on this journey alone
you don't have cancer did you read my
medical history I could have cancer I'm
sure do you want cancer
we're gonna be here by your side through
all of this friends to the end not that
you're gonna die soon
this cancer did the doctor say it was
from me we didn't know not to smoke when
we were pregnant it was a different time
I never should have taken
hallucinogenics though why are you lying
about having cancer my friends are
sleepwalking through their lives and
they were forgetting about me these
girls are my family they matter on a
level that blood never could yeah we are
having fun tonight
[Music]
normal behavior is super crucial for a
speedy healthy recovery
foreign
[Music]
you still got a tab to pay
what's going on in there I'm coming in
no don't
[Music]
you are bald we are bald
she okay
she's drunk